on a appris à tout à l'heure la mort de
l'un de nos confrères frédéric leclerc
imhoff a été tué aujourd'hui en ukraine
il a été touché par un éclat d'obus
alors qu'il voyageait à bord d'un bus
humanitaire confirmation du président de
la république vous voyez son tweet
s'afficher un instant sur vos écrans
c'est précisément l évacuation de civils
qu'il tentait de couvrir pour sa
rédaction bfm tv la chaîne a fait part
de son immense douleur frédéric leclef
rim aux fêtes est âgé 32 ans on va tout
de suite écoutez la prise de parole de
la chef de la diplomatie française
depuis kiev catherine colonna et pour
que chacun sache ce qui se passe
j'ai parlé au président élise qui je lui
demandais de faire tout son possible
pour que les autorités ukrainiennes
nous aident et permettent le retour de
votre confrère à sa famille le plus
rapidement possible une traque les
formalités légales seront accomplis il
m'a promis qu'il aiderait
de même j'ai appelé le gouverneur de la
région et après qu il
my fort mise sur les circonstances de ce
drame je lui demandai également son aide
il nous l'accorderont également je
voulais vous dire aussi mon respect
votre travail est indispensable s'il
vous plaît faites attention nous sommes
dans un pays en guerre
mesure est toujours la nécessité
d'informer et les risques que vous
prenez le plus le plus justement
possible
demandez quoi concernant bank est alors
qu'elle sera menée par les autorités
ukrainiennes c'est une zone d'ailleurs
qui n'est pas accessible qui est une
zone de combat et nous serons lien par
le canal de l'ambassade par le centre
spécialisé du quai d'orsay pour avoir
les remontées d'informations sur les
circonstances précises qui sont celles
que vous connaissez un convoi qui par un
journaliste qui insiste pour noter dans
ce convoi est malheureusement un obus
qui tombaient à proximité qui le blesse
mortellement